[Musique]
donc aujourd'hui avec les élites g ou
plutôt les j l mixer le truc et c'est la
première fois qu'on va rentrer dans un
cerveau collectif c'est à dire que tout
ce qu'il ya derrière vous que vous voyez
pas encore mais que il voit la caméra
c'est votre cerveau
alors c'est joli c'est possible là on
est dans votre club pariétal et c'est ce
qu'ils gèrent elles des sensations et
tout est là individuellement c'est quoi
la sensation la plus agréable pour vous
dans votre vie la sensation que j'ai
c'est que ça commençait à être l'été est
déjà ça commence à sentir bon ça ya une
odeur tu vois ça rappelle aussi quand on
était à l'école pratique en fait sa
lettre les grandes vacances c'est le
dernier jour de classe ou en fait on
s'en fout un peu tout et après tu vas
voir tes potes et y fait chaud dans
votre bataille d'eau et tout ça m'a
vraiment ça nous analysons d une
sensation conquis fin c'est la fin la
phase donc c'est andorre ah oui ouais
depuis qu'on est tout petit à chaque
fois on s'endort rire monde j'étais dans
la phase la phase vraiment
endormissement genre vois pas où tu sais
que tu attends dormir dans presque
entendre est relatée dans la somnolence
ouais c'est ça ça en fait été cru que tu
viens au cours mois les premières fois
où j'ai vécu la face et en four ce
moment aux thèses usa tu sens que tu ne
peux pas te suit pas ouais il ya quand
même une sensation qui est incroyable et
je m'étais jamais fait la remarque
c'est complètement en coin mais c'est
quand tu as vraiment très très très très
soif
je trouve que non mais le goût de l'eau
quand tu bois cette gorge à la haye les
noms mais c'est trop bon à chaque fois
que ce soit vrai que je suis là messi
trop bon lot en fait vraiment et ironie
opaque et ron kian qui a dit
qu'aujourd'hui il en a fait un sketch
dans l'ancien spectacle d'impulsion
enfin ils en parlaient un moment donné
oui mais je m'étais retrouvé aussi là
dedans dit quand tu es petit quand tu es
gamin et tu cours à la cour de récré
amende et à safetic mais sous le truc et
là tu vois comme ça jamais vu mais c'est
ça en fait l'assouplissement des besoins
primaires de l'esthétique et dormir en
fait la nouvelle
ça c'est une des mes questions préférées
et ça nous permet d'aller dans votre
réseau neuronal donc comment se passe
avec vous trois les prises de décision
est-ce qu'on est plus dans le cerveau
partager ou est-ce qu'on a plus petit a
eu un recul julia non en fait je pensais
que je pensais justement que lui c'est
moi en général on a un peu le même genre
c'est plutôt feeling instinctif et les
opus cérébrale dans les prises de
décisions je pense qu'en général il ya
la toute première phase c'est ouf parce
que tu me fait me poser des questions
que sa part imposé en vraiment genre et
du conte à ressortir de là se trouve une
rapide et l'hygiène non je crois que la
première phase c'est genre le cerveau il
est collectif donc on se dit ok casque
et bien qu est-ce qui est pas bien et
ensuite on retrouve chacune notre
cerveau individuel chaque échappée
ces gens dont moi c'est ça je suis
désolé oui mais non tu peux pas penser
ça alors que moi c'est ça moi c'est ça
donc là cette cogite là qui peut durer
deux semaines
vraiment on va mettre des débats pendant
deux semaines et ensuite le cerveau
collectif revient il ya plusieurs phases
brainstorming qui est très différent et
faire la fin on arrive à trouver les
points communs pour se mettre d'accord
en fait tu sais y'a un truc qui
s'appelle la dissonance cognitive convie
tous tu vois c'est par exemple je dis je
me remette le sport j'y vais pas mais en
fait je me trouve des excuses pour pas
être en dissonance intérieurement tu vas
des machins et du coup je crois qu'à
vous 3 c'est pareil en fait au départ
yenni de départ et après pour pas qu'ils
aient de dissonance entre vous trois
fleurs trouver les compromis entre vous
pour retrouver le collectif et c'est moi
j'avais vu ça avec des duo d'humoristes
tu vois c'est passé pas déjà pas simple
mais avec un trio et se rend plus sûrs
de la sensibilité musicale et sur
peut-être des envies d qui font des
trucs plus de carrière où j'en sais rien
j'imagine même pas le bordel que ça peut
être et c'est là où je me dis ok il faut
être très proches depuis très longtemps
pour que ça tienne ce genre de bail
parce que tu es obligé de passer par un
peu de conflits au minimum comme un mini
toujours toute façon je pense que si m6
a pas de conflit c'est comme tout en
fait je crois que c'est comme le succès
imagine t au top tout le temps que
mâcher au bon moment enfin t'as pas de
papa ce truc d'ascenseur entre plus
toujours autant de dons si on était tout
le temps d'accord ça serait fade et puis
surtout que mais est ce que ce sera
aussi qui font après tu vas parce que du
coup quand on joue les morceaux sur
scène tu sais tout ce par quoi on n'est
pas ces genres et des chansons tu dis
[ __ ] celle là je la détestais
finalement je la kiffe d'un salaire je
l'aimé bien non non je n'aime plus mais
une fois que tu arrives sur scène on
kiffe tout pareil c'est tout ce qu'on
fait parce que il ya eu toutes ces
embrouilles tous ces trucs avant et je
vous dis genre mais s'est pour sa part
en plus il met sur la table un truc j'ai
même pas pensé c'est à dire que
individuellement il y en a qui préfèrent
telle ou telle chanson de l'album de
telle ou telle chanson et tout et après
le fait de le vivre collectivement sur
scène et le live ça mais en fait tu
finis par procuration le kiff des deux
centres aussi quoi de confiance on se
dit ok je pense pas comme ça elles
pensent comme ça elle en est certaine
même si aux débutants un peu tu vois et
isartis en bas tu peux dire ok d'accord
jeu quand même à essayer d'aller dans
son sens ce match même si je suis pas
d'accord et au final c'est ça ce qui
fait que ça nous donne aussi des idées
puis comme ça ce soit on passe de la
mémoire épisodique donc sur la mémoire
oui en fait acheté nul c'est quoi vos
premiers souvenirs de alors j'ai bien
expliqué de sa marche notre musique
plaît en gros c'est à quel moment où
vous vous dites non pas ok la musicale
créée tout parce que c'est écouter parce
que ces publicités au camp mais à quel
moment donné vous vous êtes dit il se
passe un truc qui va être un truc de
durable tu vois où est ce que peut-être
vous l'avez jamais perçu et vous avez
vécu le truc comme c'est venu
non je me dis 50 quand je me rase eu en
fait tu vas fin quand je suis pas du
tout sûr de ce qui va se passer après je
me dis non mais de toute façon nous on
sera toujours toutes les trois donc
pourra toujours faire des petits
concerts à droite à gauche machin mais
je crois que vous êtes
oh là là tu me renferme dans mes
angoisses vraiment c'est vrai je crois
que j'ai jamais eue ce moment ou non
mais de toute façon là on sait que c'est
bon ça va remplir locle même quand ça a
pété il se passait ce truc absolument
incroyable de ou qu'on allait c'était
plein fouet et je m'étais jamais même à
l'époque mais qu'est ce qu'on est et la
tête dedans c'est arrivé d'un coup on
comprenait rien à nos vies
même à l'époque je m'étais jamais fait
la remarque de cissé montrent inquiètes
ce sera rapide
aujourd'hui même si je crois que même si
on vendait 500 600 mille albums on
serait comme ça avant de recevoir les de
remplissage des salles j'ai fait un
choix de vente du tout mais vraiment les
salons moto qu'est ce que ça va en plus
à chaque fois la tournée c'est six mois
après tu es là et ce qu'ils vont oublier
la dame
voilà si diane genre elle a été complet
tour sinon avant j'étais à mes lesquels
ils s'étaient quittés parce qu'on gagne
quant à elle en faire non franchement
c'est que même quand les gens faisaient
la queue devant l'ennemi mais oui mais
je raconte mais pourquoi écrit légende
est régisseur qui ne dis pas pour vous
non mais attends rien du tout enfin
c'est pas à ce qu'ils apprécient
haratine vraiment c'est compliqué de
réaliser ça autant de monde comme ça
qu'ils viennent fantasmant je te dis ça
mais toi tu le sais quoi ça c'est
toujours non mais celui-ci c'est un truc
que tu veux ça en fait franchir à
quelqu'un qui vient me voir dans la
ruche vraiment je te jure sincèrement je
crois qu'il va me demander l'heure où
ces photos j'ai jamais le réflexe de me
dire est en fait qui il veut me prendre
en photo
et c'est toujours très improbable mais
c'est bien aussi parce que je suis pas
sûr que des gens qui nous regardent ils
aient conscience en fait que nous mêmes
on n'a pas toujours conscience de ce qui
se passerait ce qu'on est dans de la
création et de l'artistique et en sera
jamais normal quoi tu vois c'est jamais
sa randonnée dans la normalité d'une vie
que quelqu'un sait il avoué après en
fait tu étais allé s en fou du guidon
du coup personne ne croit que c'est elle
on va passer dans votre lobe frontal
si la prise de décision et la créativité
et la question elle est super
intéressante sur une personne mais sur
trois c'est encore mieux
la créativité à trois ça se passe
comment hier dans l'excellent j'ai eu
les yeux qui pétillent a déjà fait
savoir comment ça c'est la chose qu'on
préfère dans la hâte
à chaque fois de partir en résidence
justement et on préfère il évolue en
scénic
quant à tous les techniciens taton décor
de ouf
donc du coup on fait comment ça se passe
en tout cas sur scène
déjà on a beaucoup d'instruments donc la
mise en scène à l'école on a de la
chance mais allez beaucoup autour d
inscrire il ya beaucoup de déplacements
ou là il ya beaucoup de déplacements qui
ceux qui sont en fonction des
instruments et tout n'est que trois qui
savent quand il n'y a pas d'autre mot
mais il ya des choses d'instruments que
deux personnes
c'est ça et
bah ils israël un peu leader quand même
sur la scène comédien parler en fait je
leur laisse pas trop le choix
mais elles sont tellement cool qu'elle
laisse faire et est bon prendre modèle
sur comment mettre des stops un sac en
général et lisa l'arène avec plein
d'idées sur plein de chansons car en
général c'était complètement fou on est
venu nous faire faire des personnages
c'est chaud lorsque tu nous tiens donc
on a fait faire des trucs de ouf mais
parce qu'elles seront pas concède même
de quoi elles sont capables à besançon
une fois que la confiance en henri
servira donc ça doit nous pousse à faire
des trucs qu'on n'aurait jamais fait
mais après huit ans fait le truc c'est
que sur scène puisque en vrai c'est vrai
pour la compo c'est encore différent
pour la compo marche vachement en puzzle
est en passe passe car il peut avoir une
idée toutes les deux et l'envoya lucie
toutes les deux juliette et de l'envoi
vraiment s'il n'y a pas trop de méthodes
précises parfois c'est la musique avant
parfois sembler juliette la ja de trois
chansons de l'album où j'étais du hockey
j'en ai parlé de ça hop chanson ou non
ont narré avec une chanson et où
juliette ou lui disait là dessus ce
serait cool de parler ça vraiment la
bonne méthode par contre c'est vrai que
sur scène quand on sait qu'on va aller
sur scène je leur dis ok vous mais ces
deux semaines je reviens de semaine
après me disent ça c'est pas possible ça
c'est pas possible
tous les déplacements c'est parce que
moi je ne pense pas du tout
malheureusement au fait que juliette la
troisième set sur scène que peut-être va
devoir courir de pratique avant
praticable elle me dit non mais là ils
disent ah je peux pas faire ça trois
chansons de suite ok bon ben on change à
cette liste on fait comment le ciel est
là avec ses bâtons dix ans mais je sais
pas faire de percu alors si en fait je
peux le faire voilà tu peux le faire en
fait tu sais le faire
elle s'est mise à jouer de la base des
trucs mois sacré qui fait de les voir
enfin je sais pas quand je suis sur
scène je me rends compte que c'est son
fond de fusion c'est trop beau c'est
concernant la dopamine tu sais on a on a
des substances endogène qu'on développe
nous même tu vas te le site hocine c'est
celle des câlins tu as des interventions
sociales et/ou qui comblait par les
laïcs aujourd'hui sur instagram sa tenue
le même truc c'est pour ça en fait qu on
est accro à ça c'est pas du tout le
sujet de cette vidéo
ouais en fait ça remplace et la dopamine
on dit souvent les applis se développent
de la dopamine mais non la dopamine
c'est plutôt l'hormone qui nous et
délivrer en cas de succès
de dépassement de soi de choses comme ça
quand tu as réussi quelque chose quand
tu as réussi un exploit du sport buts et
des passes et tu vois c'est ça que
quitter envoyée et du coup je me dis que
vous c'est ce qui arrive comme un
morceau est achevée et j'ai une question
celle où je me lie à quel moment donné
vous dites là le morceau mais jamais ok
en fait c'est la première fois que je
peux sauter la question à quelqu'un et
je me suis vraiment demandé j'en parlais
avec fanny avec qui je prépare les
vidéos aussi je le dis tu vois un
peintre à quel moment donné si je pose
le pinceau je touche plus à ça tu alors
en fait je me suis demandé si fièrement
les hôpitaux c'est à dire non quand même
ici super as aimé par exemple si dans
les summer comment laisser faire dans
les reprises qu'on fait en juin il ya
plus un truc où c'est comme ça qu'elle
arrive à la fin on est là la s'échange à
défoncer tout sur les compos il ya quand
même un truc où c'est dur c'est dur et
en plus toutefois pour moi il peut être
finie mais pas pour aider à juniville et
du coup moi je peux adoré comme ça les
seules vont vouloir changer des trucs
enfin à mais les équipes ont joué ses
connaissances à acquérir en vrai les
chansons avec les versions vague web et
du coup qui l'a écrit machin avait 18
quoi et on est là genre non non revenir
à la baisse un grand là on a envoyé un
morceau en mx par exemple avec jette on
est en train de leur travail et il est
déjà parti en mx1 c'est que cette date
des chances donc tu te mets tu te mets
une barrière et après le touquet le live
elles peuvent retravailler la chanson tu
vas celle du coup tu vois pas ce que
vous faites plus du spectacle vivant que
de la production artistique figé en fait
qu'est ce que tu penses déjà à tacen
passer ça en fait c'est ce qu'on dit
là on a des limites bamba ok tant pis on
fait ça on pense que sur l'instant c'est
fini mais on se serait ce pas dire que
ce sera plus jamais tu voudras jamais
venir et tout parce que et en plus c'est
bien ce que ça veut dire que les gens
qui viennent nous voir en concert bas
ils ont aussi la surprise de camp et ce
projet et même les se bat parfois on les
réarrange soit franchie les petits bouts
on a un peu d'aidé je crois qu'en studio
on n'est pas hyper on n'est pas aidé par
un groupe de studio on a retenu leur
studio c est même au niveau de commandes
sans je sais que pour moi c'est
stressant l'enregistrer je crois que
pour juliette aussi cesserait fin c'est
des trucs ou cancellé période quand on
fait des maquettes et où on est dans
lequel total et dès qu'il faut figer le
trouve donc passé derrière ton micro
jouer juste chanter juste jouer et ait
chanté taille ses impressions c'est
vraiment c'est je pense que vous faites
l'armée vous mettre dans la moisson tu
vois on n'enregistrait pas vraiment
aussi en studio
bah oui oui moi c'est ça c'est ce que
l'ancien chemin queen par exemple il
était même pièce et puis voilà il
tournait jusqu'à ce que ce soit parfait
qu'ils aient la bonne prise non soit on
enregistre way séparément et jusqu'à ce
que ça soit parfait enfin parfait la
présence du coup c'est pour ça que
parfois l'émotion l'énergie en fait elle
est pas là alors que sur scène ben voilà
on est trois ans - la complicité on
al'envie en même temps quoi faire quoi
être interprète c'est super dur td je
comprends ta des chanteurs ou des
chanteuses qui est niveau de
l'interprétation sont ouf
et je trouve que c'est si c'est ce que
tu dis est en fait c'est super dur de se
détacher de la technique pour aller
uniquement vers l'interprétation est
souvent enfin parfois heureusement que
je l'étalé là en studio elle monte à
tort les véritables réfugiés genre tu
serais pas mais n'était pas contente et
heureusement parce que fin déjà entre
autres le dernier album est celui qui
arrive on sent que c'est enfin voilà on
a on a quand même on est allé un peu
plus loin au niveau 2 au niveau de sa
que ce qu'on faisait avant mais c'est
parce que voilà encore une fois on est
tous les trois à se pousser vers l'avant
et qu'il ya des gens qui nous entourent
aussi moi j'ai hâte d'écouter vraiment
le troisième album
je mettrai les infos dans la description
pour tout le monde mais parce que en
même temps tu sais quand je suis un
auteur je tu vois son évolution à lui à
l'homme ou à la femme derrière offert
mesure des livres quand tu regardes et
one man show des spectacles tu vois
aussi la personne qui va dans le kit
heureuse un peu plus profond en l3 et je
trouve que aussi ça se ressent dans les
musiques de groupe et du coup là je
pense qu'on va encore plus vous
connaître tu vois ce que le dire à
l'intérieur du troisième j'ai hâte
d'écouter ça en espérant que ça va merci
beaucoup d'être venu merci à toi merci à
vous et donc le rendez vous est pris
on s'est dit que parce qu'en fait pour
que vous sachiez comment son arrivée
avait bondi à tunisair du mentalist que
j'ai fait c'est pas du tout concept
chaque fois quand vous gé ce soit dans
une salle où chez moi oui importe où je
vous rejoins avec une caméra et on
j'écris un truc de mentalist pour vous
trop bas trop mais un revers si beaucoup